with another loss are you worried for
your job
again i like
i don't get into any speculation on any
of that i just my job what my job is to
do is is to make sure that each and
every week
i'm giving it everything i can as a
coach and as a leader you know with
these guys so i have to make sure that i
do that and any other thing that's a
distraction that would be taken away
from our team and and that would be not
good for for me or them and i just so i
don't even get into that
that negan was the coach of the year
just two years ago his first season with
the bears they won the division and
almost won a wild card playoff game now
the rumors the speculation
are swirling and have been that naggy
could be out that gm ryan pace could be
out at least naggy can say
i didn't pick mitchell trubisky over
patrick mahomes actually nagy got
patrick mahomes for one year when he was
in kansas city before he got the job but
peter i think we are firmly into the
point where the silence from the bears
is deafening if you're going to keep
these guys we are close enough to the
end of the season that someone needs to
come out and say so just like the lions
did last year with matt patricia and bob
quinn
and the absence of any indication from
the bears organization that big changes
won't be made
tells us that there's a pretty damn good
chance that big changes will be made
mike i'll be very surprised if some
significant change isn't made uh at the
top of the bears football operations
um there's just too much
uh too much has gone wrong
and and you know you might say well geez
they're just two years removed from
doing x y and z unfortunately in the nfl
two years
has become a lifetime
and i i guess i would i would make this
point even though
i'm sure when i make it
uh bears fans from uh dekalb to
carbondale are gonna be throwing a brick
through their tv
and i would just say
you know i got to know matt nagy a
little bit early on in chicago
and obviously
excuse me when he was late in his career
in kansas city
the one thing that i knew about him was
he really was a total absolute sponge
off andy reed
and in my opinion
you said it at the top
and that is that i'm not sure that bill
walsh was going to make a really good
quarterback out of
uh mitchell trubisky i'm not sure
anybody was going to do that and so
my whole thing is
i would hate to see matt nagy go back
somewhere in in 2021 if he gets fired as
an offensive coordinator somewhere and
then maybe later getting another chance
to be a head coach when you got the
coach of the year sitting on your mantel
piece you know you're probably going to
get at least considered down the road
but my only thing is
i think that i would rather have a
situation
if they're going to do something i would
rather see them fire pace and keep negi
and also be able to pick his next
quarterback whoever that is going to be
and then get a fair chance to work with
them
that always creates an awkward dynamic
though peter when you bring in a new gm
and you tell the new gm this is your
coach because we saw it with bob quinn
two years later jim caldwell's out and
to go way back and bears fans will throw
another brick through their tv when
they're reminded of this when jerry
angelo became the gm late in the 2001
offseason he wanted to get rid of dick
geron and he ended up being stuck with
dick geron because dick duran went to
the playoffs won the division in 2001.
he wanted to bring in angelo did lovey
smith and he eventually did after he
tried to get nick saban but the the the
reality is when you get these these
tracks that aren't on the same page
it makes it hard going forward and and
it's a shame if nagi gets caught up in
that
that they if they have to get rid of
pace
do they have to get rid of naggy can you
keep nagi and bring in a gm who wants to
work with him that just it creates a
potential mess and
it's a mess for the bears it's a mess
for team president ted phillips who's
made it 21 years without any real
scrutiny and he could be gone too peter
by the time this is all said and done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports